[Music]
and coming up at 11:30 a little later
this hour we're going to talk to
Boston's Police Commissioner about
really a lot of the questions that
Deborah's posing where this
investigation stands where it goes from
here how serious were the threats and
also how officers knew that they had to
make their move when they did let's
continue this discussion though let's
bring in Robert Spencer he is with the
American Freedom Defense Initiative as
well as the Director of jihad watch
Robert you walk you work hand inand with
Pamela Geller tell us when did you
become aware of this
threat well the uh way we found out
about about it as a matter of fact was
through CNN when they contacted Pamela
Geller for comment asking her what she
thought about having been the target of
this Jihad Terror plot and uh this was
the first that uh she had learned about
it uh FBI officials had said that
something was a foot but had not been
specific however it has to be said to
their credit that they were obviously on
the case and they knew that this was
coming down and they stopped it from
happening and so uh even if they didn't
fully inform us of all that was going on
they did their job the Boston Police
Commissioner has essentially said that
the thoughts of going after Pamela
Geller that was more wishful thinking
that the real Target in the end did
appear to be Boston police officers
nevertheless Robert you know you're
appearing right now at an undisclosed
location uh do you fear for your
safety oh there's no doubt about it this
is not a joke and it was not wishful
thinking in the case of the Pamela
Geller plot I can tell you that the FBI
met with her last week and they told her
that something serious was a foot but
they didn't give her specifics now we
know what it was but uh this was never a
joke this was never wishful thinking he
only changed his mind on Tuesday morning
he was actually going to go to New York
until the morning he was killed when he
attacked the police officers so uh this
was a very real plot and of course there
are uh uh there's every reason to take
seriously their threats against Pamela
Geller and they said everyone who's
associated with her so I take that
seriously and take precautions as well
so Pamela has said one thing um that
that has has stuck out recently I wanted
to ask you about she has said that Isis
is here Isis is in America and This is
war with that in mind especially in
light of this threat um and the threat
you guys have been under from your
perspective how do you wage that war how
do you fight that enemy what's what's
your prescription if you will what we
are doing is trying to show what needs
to be done in order to win this war and
that's to show that we will count out a
violent intimidation they're trying to
frighten Americans into silence and
submission they're trying to say you
have to do what we say you have to not
do what we want and do what we want and
and if you do not we will kill you and
the mainstream media including CNN is
going not change going forward in light
of this threat you don't change you
don't change how you're what you guys
are doing there's nothing we're never
going to surrender and never going to
submit the the media is submitting by
not showing the cartoons and cow to to
this violent threats and intimidation
that's just the wrong thing to do
because it's only going to encourage
more violent threats and intimidation
well look leave leave the media aside
for a second the media didn't Target
Pamela Geller the media didn't attack
that that conference you had in Garland
Texas the media targets Pamela Geller
all the time are you kidding the media
had this morning to talk about this we
are having you on to discuss this we are
having you on to discuss this today
let's continue to discuss it rather than
pointing fingers Pamela Geller one of
the things she did say is you have a
couple more initiatives in the works I'm
wondering tell us here what you are
planning going
forward well we're going to be we're
going to be announcing those very soon
and uh they do involve uh the cartoons
of Muhammad that the media refuses out
of fear to show and uh we are the only
ones who are show who are willing to
stand and say we are not going to be
frightened and and cowed into silence
and submission the the the jihadis made
the cartoons the flash point we didn't
the jihadis made the cartoons the point
at which the freedom of speech is is
being challenged if we do not meet them
on that point then the freedom of speech
as a whole will be
lost Robert this plot this most recent
plot this originated in Boston have you
guys reached out to the Muslim Community
in Boston to work on how to engage how
to gain a better understanding how to
work together to to fight extremist
views the Islamic Society of Boston that
uh the Usama raheim was a member was
also the mosque that was attended by the
sarv brothers by AIA sadiki who's doing
86 years in prison for an Al-Qaeda plot
by TK Mahana who's doing 17 years for an
Al-Qaeda plot by Ahmed Abu Samra who was
the Islamic States propagandist who was
just recently reportedly killed uh it it
was founded by abdurahman Al 23 years
for funding
Al-Qaeda islet part this is the Islamic
societ Muslim the Islam Society of
Boston needs to be investigated it
doesn't need to be partnered with it
inves talking about one group though
here just to be clear you're not saying
every Muslim the group that is a group
that is a group the question is yes the
question is where are the Muslims in
Boston who are protesting against the
Islamic Society of Boston where are the
Muslims in Boston who are saying not in
my name the ISB doesn't represent me I
don't stand for the kinds of things that
are obviously being taught in those
mosques Robert Spencer uh we wish you
continued safety we thank you coming on
uh and we look forward to Future
discussions with you thanks so much
thanks robt thanks very much